let's talk about the worst drinks that
can dissolve your teeth okay i'm talking
about dissolving your enamel around your
teeth enamel is a very complex substance
it is the hardest substance in your
entire body it's harder than bone but if
we look at bone the jaw bone is the
hardest of all the bones and so the
question is what has the capacity to
dissolve this enamel and give you
cavities is it just the acids or certain
things in the foods well
we're going to talk about that let's
first talk about different things that
you can drink
that are acidic now when i talk about
acidic i'm talking about ph and the ph
goes from 1 to 14.
14 being extremely
alkaline and 1 being extremely acid and
right in the middle 7 you have something
neutral okay so the higher the ph above
7 the more alkaline it is and the lower
things are below seven the more acid
things are and so if you were going to
talk about a ph of one you're talking
about battery acid and then if you go up
one to three we're dealing with
hydrochloric acid and acid in your
stomach
and when we're dealing with
distilled water we're dealing with
completely neutral seven mineral water
is slightly above seven it can actually
go up to eight
sometimes even nine because of the
dissolved minerals and the
bicarbonates they're called which is
slightly alkaline now let's talk about
lemon juice
lemon juice has a ph between two and
three so it's very very acidic but
typically when you drink lemon water
you're going to be putting a small
amount of lemon juice into water you're
not going to basically bathe your mouth
with lemons necessarily but you might
but basically you're going to take a
tablespoon of lemon juice
and put it in your water and so if we
combine the water plus the lemon the ph
actually rises
to roughly about 5.5 now if we take
apple cider vinegar which is also very
acidic between two and three because of
the acetic acid
you're also not going to drink that
straight hopefully you're not going to
drink that straight you're going to
dilute it with water and the ph is going
to come up to about 4.5
to maybe 5 depending on if you're using
a tablespoon or a teaspoon and then we
get into the carbonated waters right you
have carbonic acid and that could
fluctuate between five to five point
five to maybe even six
so carbonated water is slightly acidic
and then we have coffee which is acidic
it's a five and t
which roughly is about the same but
maybe a little bit less acidic so
5 to 5.5 and then you have beer which is
acidic we have 4 to 4.5 and then we have
soft drinks like
coke which is roughly between 2.4 to 3.
so that's actually very very acidic and
so when we're dealing with ph in enamel
you start to get demineralization which
means the breakdown of minerals on your
teeth which are about 96 percent
minerals
at a ph about 5.5 but it's all about how
long
that your teeth are exposed to these
acids so if you're drinking apple cider
vinegar diluted with water or lemon or
drinking coffee for a short period of
time it's not nearly as bad as if you're
going to chronically do it all day long
so we have one variable of exposure
and then we have another variable of how
acid something is and then we have
another variable that i want to talk
about which is actually probably the
most important
factor and that is your own saliva now
your saliva normally should be between
6.2 to
7.6 okay
with an average of being slightly acidic
but not too much i'd say 6.7 now in
slava you have minerals you have sodium
you have calcium you have potassium
you have bicarbonates that help buffer
acids you have antimicrobial factors you
have immune factors you have cortisol
and you have enzymes so you may drink
certain things periodically through the
day
but really the saliva in your mouth is
there chronically it's always there so
the ph of your saliva is a much more
important factor
to buffering these acids because one of
the purpose of saliva is to buffer some
of the acids and also reduce the
bacterial count and that's another
factor i want to talk about the bacteria
in your mouth the bacteria in your mouth
it fed certain things like carbs start
to ferment these carbohydrates and start
to change the ph in your mouth and so
the bacteria can keep your ph very acid
and the bacteria are usually at the root
of this
dissolving of your enamel and yes you
guessed it it's the carbohydrates i'm
talking about sugar
that really makes your mouth very acidic
not directly but indirectly because they
feed the bacteria that then produce
byproducts which are acidic so
normally when you drink apple cider
vinegar diluted or lemon water
it's not a really big factor unless you
also have all these bacteria that are
constantly producing these acids in your
mouth all that long and so the worst
thing that you can drink
that will dissolve your teeth is
something with acid
and sugar at the same time and yes i'm
talking about juice especially if you're
a young child or even a baby the worst
thing to feed a baby
is
juice because
it's basically pure sugar with acids and
the younger you are the less strong the
enamel is babies are very very
susceptible to having things dissolve
the teeth because enamel has not
developed into a very strong layer yet
so you never want to give your baby
juice not to mention give your baby soda
which i've seen before which i have to
withhold myself because
sometimes people are offended if i speak
up now
since we're on the topic of children
if the child is consuming things like
sour candy where you have
a stickiness of the candy you have the
sugar
and then you have these candies that are
very very acid like that would be very
very bad to give a child and then you
have the child that's sucking on a
lollipop right constant exposure to
sugar or chewing gum all day which i
used to do as a child or what about
sports drinks which are basically sugar
water or energy drinks which are sugar
water or even dried fruit all these
things are going to breed more bacteria
that are going to acidify your mouth and
potentially dissolve your teeth and i
also forgot to mention in soft drinks
you have a very specific type of acid
called phosphoric acid and phosphoric
acid is probably the worst acid to
dissolve
teeth because it starts to leach out the
calcium now there's two other factors i
want to talk about number one
is that
you really want to look at this problem
as a systemic problem if someone's a
diabetic or a pre-diabetic or
they have insulin resistance because
they're consuming a lot of carbs
then we're dealing with a chronic level
of high blood glucose which does come
into the teeth indirectly
through the roots your teeth have a
blood supply so a lot of times people
have this idea that it's just the tooth
exposed to sugar in your mouth that is a
big problem but what about internally
what about the roots of the tooth if you
have high blood sugars that's a systemic
cause of a breakdown of your tooth as
well but from the inside out and also
let's talk about the
socket that the tooth
is in
the gums okay
which require a good amount of vitamin c
because it's all collagen and vitamin c
complex help make up collagen and
there's a very interesting relationship
between the chemistry of sugar and the
chemistry of vitamin c
they're near identical so when someone
is consuming sugar all day or exposing
their mouth to sugar the body will not
absorb vitamin c at the same time so if
given a choice the body will always
take up sugar
uh before vitamin c so in other words
sugar blocks vitamin c and what do you
think that's going to do to your gums in
fact if you ever look at someone that
has bleeding gums or red swollen gums
that is a classic vitamin c deficiency
it's a subclinical version of scurvy or
even scurvy itself gingivitis and
bleeding gums is a symptom of scurvy but
in reality nowadays it's probably just
consuming too much sugar and the vitamin
c cannot be absorbed so should you be
concerned about drinking apple cider
vinegar and lemon in your water if it's
diluted well not necessarily if you're
on a low carb diet but you can always
just use a straw to avoid the exposure
of your teeth and then when you're done
with these drinks you can always just
drink some water to flush out some of
these acids but your saliva has a job of
buffering these acids so an average
person produces about like three cups of
saliva every single day and for my
friend in germany dennis who still is
trying to figure out what that converts
into
milliliters one cup which is actually
less than this is about
750 milliliters or 25
ounces now that you have more awareness
on what can affect the enamel on your
teeth
i think it's really important to
understand now the benefits of apple
cider vinegar and lemon water check this
one out right here
you